I people i'm pretty happy with the
product at the topical application
thumbs up thumbs up and look at okay
excellent okay we are less confident
with number 20 with double work this is
interesting because multiplication and
division they are really the same thing
but viewed in Reverse okay I suppose
maybe you know if you have your parents
or your crunches to drive you know
driving in Reverse it is actually kinda
more weird difficult than driving
forwards so maybe it isn't that
surprising that division is harder than
multiplication but if you have a look
through and this looks really good i
think Christians done a fantastic job
with the working you can see he set up
the division right here and we're going
through step-by-step what are things I
really like is that he hasn't skipped
anything you can see he's put these
zeros in here what do they indicate what
are they about unica very good 37 the
what's it call you start to the day it's
a divisor all right the divisor doesn't
go any times in 21 it doesn't go any
times in 210 you've got to go all the
way to the third DJ and a 100 you can
fit it twice and then you go all the way
through in that same huh okay now let's
have a look at the last question this is
what we can focus you on most recently
and this is a really good stuff it looks
to me like the numbers are okay thumbs
up on the numbers yeah okay what I am
going to add on to that and maybe if
your answers look like this because I
saw a few people wrote down some almost
identical to this I'm going to add a
little bit extra to it okay yeah yeah
yeah go ahead
yep you might have unnoticed here our
parallel lines they have no names right
like they don't have our letters on
those so you can't call them anything if
you just take our life that's perfect
and as we've noticed these different
kinds of angles that we've got they're
not always equal right in fact if you
have a look at this one it's not 101
it's something quite different so I
think that's outstanding interestingly I
probably would have done the colorful I
probably would have done this line first
think about it for a second apply some
logic with me okay this angle B it is co
interior what's it can t really r yeah
it's continuing a right so if I want to
use the papers car interior these guys
together I kind of need to know what a
is first before I can do anything so I
think this comes first and then this
comes second right on top of that can I
get a more detailed wedding for what
would I one of our foot here on the side
someone else's said anything you the
reasons for co interior angles that was
the most recent one yeah okay so we have
language for this right we have words
that are small so simple add up to 180
what's the word starts with an S yeah
Doran's some some some polychaetes yet
the the Sun right with a so many 180
when there's 100 need really
specifically we call that a
supplementary okay which admittedly is
all work by it so important with you so
I'm going to say here go into your
angles on parallel lines and I'm going
to use that supplementary word right
there not equal they're supplementary
okay it's really vital that you get that
explanation down because I'm trying to
make an argument I'm trying to convince
you you know different debater gone up
it's like I as the first paper of the
affirmative reckon yeah I think it's
true and then they sat down you'd be
like what I'm not convinced at all you
want an argument in there you have
details okay question
okay so yep yep good so you actually can
do it that way if you like if some of
you like that be first that's okay
however be careful this is not the
reason that these two angles are
connected it's a different reason
there's different logic what is the
reason why being 101 are supplementary
in that case yeah very good these are
angles are adding to a straight angle to
180 degrees okay I'm they're not common
Tyrion they actually have opposite sides
of this sub parallel line right so this
is true if I do it in reverse order if I
want to do be first I need a different
reason okay absolutely